Traductor: Yoshinori Casas
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
Los peces están en problemas.
La población de bacalao fuera de la costa
este de Canadá colapsó en los 90,
la pesca recreacional
y comercial intensiva
ha diezmado la población
del mero gigante al sur de la Florida,
y la población de atún
se ha desplomado cerca del 50 %,
con el atún rojo del Atlántico Sur
al borde de la extinción.
Estos son algunos ejemplos
dentro de muchos.
La sobrepesca está sucediendo
alrededor del mundo.
¿Cómo sucedió esto?
Cuando alguien piensa en la pesca,
se imagina relajado en un bote
recogiendo la captura del día.
Pero la pesca industrial moderna,
la que llena nuestros supermercados,
parece más una guerra.
De hecho, las tecnologías que usan
fueron desarrolladas para la guerra.
Radar,
sonar,
helicópteros,
y aviones de observación
son utilizados para guiar barcos-fábrica
hacia la disminución de peces.
Líneas largas con ganchos o redes gigantes
rodean cantidades masivas de peces,
junto con otras especies,
cómo aves marinas, tortugas o delfines.
Los peces son arrastrados
dentro de botes gigantes,
que cuentan con congelamiento instantáneo
y planta de procesamiento.
Todas estas tecnologías nos han permitido
atrapar peces en grandes profundidades
y mar adentro cómo nunca antes.
Así como la distancia y profundidad
de la pesca ha aumentado,
también la cantidad de especies.
Por ejemplo, la merluza negra
ni suena ni luce muy apetitosa.
Los pescadores la ignoraron
hasta finales de los 70.
Entonces fue renombrada y comercializada
a los chefs en EE. UU. como mero chileno,
aunque el pez es realmente
un tipo de bacalao.
Pronto el pescado estuvo presente
en el mercado mundial
y ahora es un manjar.
Desafortunadamente, estos
peces de agua profunda
no se reproducen hasta
que alcanzan los 10 años de edad,
haciéndolos muy vulnerables
a la sobre pesca
al ser capturados jóvenes
antes de poder reproducirse.
El gusto del consumidor y el precio
pueden tener un efecto nocivo.
Por ejemplo, la sopa de aleta de tiburón
es un manjar en China y Vietnam
y la aleta se ha convertido
en la parte más rentable del tiburón.
Esto lleva a los pescadores
a llenar sus botes con aletas
dejando atrás millones
de tiburones muertos.
Estos problemas no son solo
del mero chileno y el tiburón.
El 31% de la población mundial
de peces sufre sobrepesca
y otro 58 % son pescados
por encima del máximo nivel sostenible.
Los peces no se reproducen tan rápido
para alimentar 7 mil millones de personas.
La pesca también tiene un impacto
en ecosistemas más grandes.
Los camarones son atrapados arrastrando
redes del tamaño de un campo de fútbol
a lo largo del fondo del océano,
desorganizando o destruyendo
hábitats en el lecho marino.
Por lo general solo el 5 %
de la pesca es camarón.
El resto es captura incidental,
animales que se devuelven muertos al mar.
La crianza de camarones
en la costa no es mejor.
Destruyen los manglares para
ubicar las granjas de camarones,
robando a las comunidades protección
contra tormentas y filtración de agua
y quitándole a los peces
espacios claves de crecimiento.
¿Qué significa darle un descanso
a los peces y dejarlos recuperarse?
Se pueden proteger de varias formas.
En aguas nacionales,
el gobierno puede poner límites
de cómo, cuándo, dónde,
y cuántos pescados,
con restricciones para algunos
barcos o equipos.
Prácticas nocivas cómo dragar,
pueden ser prohibidas,
y establecer reservas marinas
cerradas para la pesca
para ayudar a los ecosistemas
a recuperarse por sí mismos.
También hay un rol para sensibilizar
al consumidor y reducir las sobras,
cómo cortar las aletas al tiburón,
y presionar a la industria pesquera
hacia prácticas más sostenibles.
Intervenciones previas han ayudado
a recuperar poblaciones de peces agotadas.
Hay muchas soluciones.
El mejor enfoque para cada pesquería
se debe basar en ciencia,
respeto a las comunidades locales
que dependen del océano
y los peces como animales salvajes.
Y se deben aplicar las normas.
Por lo general se necesita
la colaboración internacional,
porque a los peces no les importan
nuestras fronteras.
Necesitamos acabar la sobrepesca.
Ecosistemas,
seguridad alimentaria,
trabajos,
economías
y culturas costeras dependen de ella.